I stole her man media hey like to
subscribe share it it to your grandma
said it's a school principal sent it to
everybody set it to put it on a message
board about podiatry and kung fools sent
it out just push it in different zone
man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
new year calm fitness goals
some of us stick so please don't but for
me personally to have the all-star celeb
this is happening on February 14th to
kick off the year I okay this is in six
weeks
so it's real supposed to have that
concrete thing to work off is feel good
man this you know filling the progress
just getting the reps it is probably the
most shots back-to-back
I don't shoot that much in every
practice Oh sounds like that you're not
getting that MIDI up he's like a 45
minute practice there you go Oh
your kid isn't that that type of school
so like it's not getting the reps it
ain't getting that in 21 so it's kind of
surreal man's I used to be in here so I
am shooting with a [ __ ] shot machine
five weeks out from the celeb gave like
a maniac if I lean into this yeah I
think it of inform how I approach other
aspects of my my business is just career
Oh MVP